are you able to break down a script in
terms of when a script is submitted to
you for you to consider what are you
looking at
how are you sort of dissecting it to see
if it'll work I try and read a script
that's sent to me as an audience first
so the first thing I'm looking at is it
does it grab me do I care
is it a story that I feel emotional
about compelled by you know if it's a
scary movie am I scared it's the comedy
have I laughed if it's emotional have I
you know gotten a lump in my throat I
find that if I'm looking at it and
dissecting it right from the start and
I'm not doing myself any favors and I'm
not doing the script any favors if I get
to I don't know at some point it hasn't
done any of those things I usually don't
finish it but if I get to the end and I
have felt those things then I'll go back
and do a second read as with my producer
hat on which is is this affordable can
we do this will there be a part in it
for a star which as you know things
things that are too ensemble are
difficult to get made because you need a
star roll to get things ordered usually
so I know I'm looking I have the night
to point Hamlin and then the producer
hat goes okay what where would I shoot
this how much is it gonna cost is there
a star role where would was there a
network or studio that would buy this
because you don't obviously chase
something that there's no place to sell
and so then that's the second read what
are some things in a script that sort of
stick out as red flags whether it's too
many locations or even just the way the
script is written too much space on the
page too little well you can immediately
tell when a script has not been written
by a professional and obviously that
that's a big red flag so if the script
has like art on the title page or
colored paper or is not in final draft
form you know too much too much of a
header or too much on the sides you know
okay this person is either trying to get
something to be shorter or longer by
using the margins which that's
not playing fair so solos but I would
say red flags are things like you know
not introducing your protagonist in the
first 10 pages not you know announcing
what your film is you know in the first
15 pages you know don't don't wait until
halfway through to tell me oh this
movies about this guy who wants to kill
his mom okay well well I'm not sitting
here for an hour waiting for you to tell
me that so so I'm looking for the kind
of structural and character problems
that are pretty easy to spot you know
I'm not a big believer in the Robert
McKee world of inciting incident and all
that but there's value in what he has to
say sort of philosophically which is
that there are some kind of foundational
things you need to do in a screenplay
that you don't you know unless you're
doing experimental movies which I'm not
in that business if you have a story to
tell there's certain you know parts of
the roadmap you got a hit and so you
know you hold back your protagonist
until page 30 and that's just not gonna
happen
there's no you're not acting a mood @sk
a movie start to show up a half hour
into the movie so those are the kinds of
things I look for when you say you read
it as an audience member first does that
mean you're not even reading it let's
say at your desk on a computer you're
trying to see it as more of a reclining
position just more comfortable or no it
just in your mindset I am sadly very
old-school I'm the get off your lawn guy
so I forced by my development executive
Gaea to print everything I don't like to
breed anything on my computer or on my
iPad I like to have the script in my
hand I like to have tangible I want to
be able to write things on it when when
I'm reading it especially if I'm going
to read it a second time for us a
producer there's gonna be things I'm
gonna
as I'm reading and so I I like to have a
finished script so and I'll read it on
the plane I'll read it
they'll read on out in the backyard I
don't care where it is but I'd really
like plain reading because nobody can
bother me I do like I don't like to read
a script in fits and starts I would
prefer to just read it straight through
and it's hard to do that here in my
office I really can't and it's not so
easy at home either
there's aquarium and I find plane travel
to be in luxury because there's no one
calling me nobody finding me nobody
tapping me on the shoulder or no emails
no nothing so I do a lot of good reading
on planes that's really interesting
hopefully your your plane mate that's
sitting next to you isn't looking to
talk about sports or some yeah that's on
there you go the right that's the do not
Universal do not deserve exactly but
that I can relate to that or a book it's
a much different experience I don't like
to read a book on an iPad my my wife has
a Kindle my son has a Kindle I'm not a
Kindle person I like to have a book sure
there's a different experience doctor
holding that in your hand and I'm sure
we even with papers may be non recycling
friend I have the LA Times deliver to my
house I don't like to read the newspaper
online I'd much rather have you know I
like flipping back and forth I like
having the access to I'm reading the
sports section to go back to the
standings and find out what place the
Dodgers are in what I'm reading the
article on the Dodgers if I'm doing that
online I got a click back and click back
and it's it's way less I like the
tangible feeling of moving through a
paper I would miss that well it's
similar to wanting to see a film with an
audience Oh
instead of on your phone or or yes a
laptop it's not the same a hundred
percent the shared experience of
watching a movie is completely unique
one of the things I love about being a
director is I get to experience the film
more than I do as a producer and as a
television movie producer was the worst
because we'd finish our movie we turned
over the network it would go out and
we'd have no sense of if people laugh
where they were supposed to laugh do
they cry or they're supposed to cry
where they scared when they was once get
scared I didn't get to experience any of
that but if I do a feature or an indie
feature I get to go
to a theater and watch oh did it work
did did what I you know and then stand
outside and you know when when I did
perfect sisters and it was a movie about
two brilliant young high school students
who came up with the perfect crime to
kill their alcoholic mother who was a
train wreck I my goal was to get you to
the end of that film and even after they
committed this crime to still be
somewhat sympathetic to the two girls
and my favorite thing was to stand
outside the theater in here people argue
with each other
they should have gone to prison he had a
gun in prison she'd gone for longer they
shouldn't have gone ever long that's
what I that's what you want you want
them to walk out and be at odds with
with what the story you just told as
opposed to walking out and be bored or
have no no sense of outrage or anger or
or contentment or happiness there I
would you know just to have ennui is the
worst thing you can ask from an audience
do you ever fly to different cities and
get out of sort of an industry-based
town if I can I love to go to other
cities and watch but I again I came from
the television movie business so of the
sixty movies and series I've only done
three features so most of what I got I
got from relatives calling me going hey
saw your movie or what mail came out you
know friends and family or when Facebook
came out hey I saw your movie but I
don't get to get the visceral response
which I really miss I'll tell you I
directed an episode of agents of shield
in season five and again no you know
goes out and I don't know and it was gia
that told me that there's a whole
YouTube channel where people watch
something on televisions but primarily
series and videotaped themselves it was
fast
fantastic so now I got to watch people
watch my work great I mean it's a TV
movie producer we never get that we
never get that I mean I would have
screenings of all of my films before it
aired on ABC NBC CBS Fox TMT whatever
MTV whoever I was working for I was
screen at the week before for
and family I would rent a theater and
screen it because it was the only time I
was ever gonna see the audience reaction
I mean I did and I did John Candy's last
film which he directed and starred him
called hostage for a day for Fox that
was a balls out comedy and it was it was
joke joke joke joke joke character
comedy and the only way I was gonna know
if people laughed where they were
supposed to laugh was to have a
screening and we had a big screen whitby
we rented a big theater and got a big
audience and I got to see them laugh
where they were supposed to laugh which
hopefully John was there somewhere in
spirit and enjoying it as well
you